[Music]
felicia is with us in louisville hey
felicia how are you
hey hey james good how are you great how
can we help
yeah um so my husband and i we just
started at fpc er fpu and very recently
this is our first official month really
you know going all in on it cool um my
question is
we have about 12 000
in debt and we're doing this all
backward because we just started um so
we have 12 000 in debt we do have about
15 in savings though
okay um
should we go ahead and also i'm going to
be needing a new car
very soon and i have 155 000 miles miles
online
and uh
it is it is it's an explorer and i love
it but it's just it's just it's just
like about to lay down you're afraid
it is yeah and we have three kiddos so
that's the thing in car seat i'm gonna
need something that is full size that's
not
not gonna be too cheap you know and
so my question is should we go ahead and
pay off the 12 000 in debt from our
savings
and then i'm not taking a car payment um
or getting a loan for that
i don't know i'm kind of
stuck right now with this
what's your household income
um my husband just started a new job but
this is in january so right now he's
gross over a hundred thousand but we we
it's take home about six grand a month
and i stay at home with my kiddos okay
well i mean i think one of the things
that's that feels scary about this
felicia is that you know you want a car
soon but the good news is you don't need
a car right now
right now you have the savings to pay
off that debt and you're debt-free like
today
you could say that's a good income you
could save up
and that that car may lie i mean this is
speaking from someone that you know i
have driven cars into the ground in the
past and it may go a lot longer than you
think um you don't need anything right
now you've got them you'll have some
emergency fund left over anyway already
your your baby step three which is your
three to six months of emergency fund
you'll have that started with a few
grand and so if you have a repair you
need to make in the next few months when
you're saving up you can cover it make
it last a little longer and then you can
save up and pay cash for another
used
suv or whatever you need but you'll be
able to buy it in cash i think it just
feels scary because it's high mileage
but it's if it's running it's running if
right if one of your
kids was sick
and you needed money bad to pay the doc
what's the most out of your six grand
you could save a month if you had to
well we do have an hsa and we put 50
a week into that
and what does that have to do with what
i just asked you
i don't know
what is the most um we could do one of
your kids
no i don't understand because you had an
hsa okay i was trying to use i was
trying to use a metaphor and we got
sidetracked into a product
it does make sense it was my fault okay
i just i was
okay you went you went straight to the
real answer and i was trying to do okay
my point is out of that six grand if you
had to the world came to an end how much
is your house payment
um about thirteen hundred dollars a
month okay so you could save three grand
a month if you had to
if you had no payments except a house
payment
exactly okay so what i would do is pay
off all your debt today
and start saving three grand a month
until you have an emergency fund and
then keep saving until you have enough
money to buy a car in cash
okay my heart just went down to my
stomach because i'm excited not because
i'm scared to do that yeah i need to be
here oh that's good you did a good job
you did a good job you actually answered
the question i was trying to be
metaphorical and i i screwed it up so
my bad but but the uh uh but see my
point is with no payments and your
newfound intentionality with money on
paper on purpose with both you and your
husband on the same team christy's
answer is exactly correct
that you can save up an emergency fund
if things blow up while you have that
emergency fund before you have the car
then you'd have to use the emergency
fund because it'd be an emergency to buy
a little better car right
right but but you're going to be just
fine because you know
you said you've got 15 right
yeah so we got three there now next
month we'll have six the next month we'd
have nine the next month we'd have 12.
that's christmas
you got 12 000 in the bank at christmas
and no payments in the world
i and i think your car is going to make
it to christmas
i think so yeah i just only hit that
weekend i'm going oh now we have to go
you know
we'll get a new buyer's back yep well
don't don't
don't turn it into
i got forced in to do something stupid
because you already put on the table i'm
not doing car payments you're smart
there that was wise so you got this got
the right track and so if and um if
buying a car becomes an emergency slow
down breathe just a little bit but if
you can fix the old one for 500 and get
another six months out of it do that too
because i want you to save up and pay
cash for a ten thousand dollar car and
still have twelve thousand dollars in
your account and still have no payments
okay and that's that's uh
april
yeah okay
and you can do this
by april yeah i think so too
okay so hey thank you
thanks for the call that's a really good
question